this were sold for almost 7 million
dollars that money you could get 17 new
Lamborghinis dancing rain is a symbol of
the booming trade and racehorses pumped
up on Gulf money so why is she so
expensive dancing rain was a champion on
the track and she's carrying a full by
Frankel the stallion regarded as the
greatest racehorse and at least 60 years
it's easy to get excited this is a
genetic gamble and Hollywood terms she's
a bit like Angelina Jolie pregnant with
Brad Pitt's child and she won the oaks
this is John Ferguson he's just bought
dancing rain for sheikh mohammed bin
rashid al maktoum the ruler of Dubai and
one of the world's biggest breeders she
has a great pedigree and she was a
classic winner so from our point of view
she was a kind of jewel that if you're
going to breed champions you need those
kind of jewels here at Tattersalls
Europe's biggest blood stock auctioneers
revenues rose to a record 424 million
dollars last year and it's Gulf money
which is pushing up prices qatar is
where the new money is coming from and
Sheikh Fahad the cousin of the Emir is
ready to spend of course economic
climates around the world help that the
things I'll have recovered a bit so he
will have more money to spend on horses
this is risky business you can pay
millions for a horse but that's no
guarantee you're buying a winner Lord
Grimm Thorpe is the racing manager for
Prince Khalid of Saudi Arabia and he
knows about luck and so the rest in
harems the rewards are great if you get
it right and they are lucky enough but
of course the downside is still pretty
big you know this man she doesn't
produce anything that can run her value
goes down a thoroughbred is no ordinary
commodity one fall a kick or disease and
your millions are down the tube but the
mood here at Tattersalls is buoyant
prices have bounced back since 2008
money is flowing and fires are feeling
confident